Hello and welcome to our very
first episode of Route 85,
our new show just for
you iOS developers.
Ooh, do you smell that?
It's still got the
new show smell.
That's nice.
Anyway, as you probably
know, the Chrome web browser
has been available on iOS
devices for a few years now
but being able to select
your default browser has not.
So if you're a regular Chrome
user on iOS, like I am well,
you've probably got a whole
bunch of tabs open in Chrome
because that's the
browser you use every day.
But you've also got some pages
open in Safari because that's
the browser that
opens by default
when you typically click
on a link in another app.
But I wanted to show
you something here.
Take a look at this.
I'm here using my favorite
Twitter client, Tweetbot,
which I highly recommend
if you haven't seen it yet.
And here I see that Colt
McAnlis has added a link
to his perflikeapirate day talk.
Now when I click on it, it opens
in Safari, as you might expect.
But now let's go
back to Tweetbot here
and go into my
preferences over here.
And you'll notice that one
of the options I have here
is to change my default browser.
And one of those
options is Chrome so,
well heck, let's pick that.
We'll go back and now
watch what happens
when I click on
this very same link.
Well now it opens in Chrome
along with the 24 other tabs
I have open.
I have a lot of tabs.
And incidentally, this provides
me with a few other benefits
as well.
If this site required a log
in and password and Chrome
had remembered it for me from,
say, the desktop version,
I'd be able to sign in using
that password without having
to type it in.
If you look at the
settings you'll
see that over here I also
have Chrome's Data Usage
option turned on,
which does allow
me to reduce my bandwidth
if I am browsing
on a mobile network
instead of Wi-Fi.
It also turns out that if this
page were in another language
Chrome would
translate it for me.
And of course, if I were
to bookmark this article
you would see that it would show
up later on my desktop browser
if I wanted.
But I think the
nicest benefit of all,
particularly for
you app developers,
is that Chrome gives me this
nifty little Back button here
that, when I click on it, goes
right back to my Tweetbot app
where I left off.
So I can continue checking
on my Twitter news.
So how do they do that?
Well, while I haven't
seen their source code
I've got a pretty good idea
of how they pulled this off.
So this involves a technique
in iOS known as URL schemes.
The idea is that if
you were to open a URL,
like the ones pictured
here, iOS would
look at that little bit of text
before the colon and use that
to decide what
app it should open
to process the rest of the URL.
In this first
example, for instance,
mailto would open
in iOS's mail app.
Similarly, tel would open
phone, http and https
would open in Safari, and
in one kind of special case,
iOS will take any web link
that starts with maps.apple.com
and open it directly
in Apple's Maps app.
Now as third party
developers we can't
change what apps get to open
mailto, http, or tel URL
schemes but we can
declare our own schemes.
By doing so we then
declare that a URL that
starts with that string
belongs to our application.
If we do, and then
the user then attempts
to open that kind of URL,
our application gets opened
and this URL is passed to our
own app delegate to handle.
So we could create
an app that says
that a URL beginning with foo
opens up in our application.
And in fact, we'll show you how
to do this at a later point.
But I think the important
thing to know here
is that Google Chrome,
along with Maps,
and many other third
party applications
have declared their
own URL schemes.
And you can take
advantage of this
to open a URL
directly in Chrome.
Let's find out how.
So let's start by creating
a simple application.
Now at the time of this
recording Swift and Xcode 6
are still in beta
so I'm going to do
this in Objective C and Xcode 5.
Now if there's enough
interest I can certainly
redo these tutorials
in Swift as well.
That's a little something I
like to call job security.
So I'm going to create
a new project here
and I'm going to make it
a Single View Application.
Let's call it
OpeninChromeExample
because I'm really
original like that.
We're just going to make it
for the iPhone for simplicity.
And feel free to create
it wherever you'd like.
Now let's go into
our storyboard here
and I'm going to add a
button that will say oh,
let's just have it
say Open a web page.
Center it.
Gosh, look at this application.
Isn't it beautiful?
This thing is beautiful.
Oh man.
Anyway, I'm going to open
up my helper editor here
and I'm going to Control-drag
from this button into here.
And I'll create a new Action
called openWebPageWasPressed.
So now from within here
I'll create an NSURL.
We'll call it
googleURL and it will
be an NSURL, URLWithString,
and in here we'll
do https://www.google.com.
Feel free to replace this with
your own favorite web page
if you get tired of
seeing the Google Home
screen over and over.
And I'm going to have my
UIApplication sharedApplication
call openURL and I'll
have it open googleURL.
There we go.
And sure enough--
let's save this--
when I run this application,
and I click on this button,
there you go, it opens the
Google Home page in Safari.
And that's because the URL
I'm trying to open right now
begins with https,
which, as you'll recall,
iOS automatically assigns
to Safari browser.
So now let's go back
into my application here.
I'm going to go into my View
Controller and the main editor
and let's watch what
happens when I replace https
with Google Chrome.
Now when I run this, and I
click on this button, huh,
nothing happened.
And that's because I'm
running this on the simulator
where I don't have
Chrome installed.
Now this is a situation
I should check for
and I probably want to fall back
to Safari if the user doesn't
have Chrome installed, and
we'll get to that later.
But for now let's stop this.
And I'm going to switch
over from the simulator
to my actual iPhone
and run it there.
And now when you
click on this button
we see that, sure enough, my
URL now opens in Google Chrome.
Hooray.
And honestly, at
the most basic level
this is all you really
need to do, replace http
with Google Chrome and
replace https with, I guess,
let's make this Google
Chrome s to open it securely.
And voila, all your
links open with Chrome.
But let's go back to the
app running on my simulator
where I didn't have
Chrome installed.
Obviously, having
my button click
do nothing is a bad
user experience.
At the very least, I should
check for this situation
and open the link
in Safari instead.
And it turns out, there's
an easy way to do this.
In addition to UIApplications
openURL method,
it also has a Boolean
canOpenURL method
that checks to see--
with the system--
to see if there's an
application out there that
can respond to this URL scheme.
So I'm going to go back
to my button handler here
and I'm going to
create two URLs.
The first one, that I
will call mySafariURL,
it is an NSURL
URLWithString, and here we're
just going use the plain
old https URL scheme.
And this one I'm going to
rename as our Chrome URL.
And here we're using the
Google Chrome s URL scheme.
Then down here I'll
simply check and see
if my UIApplication
sharedApplication canOpenURL
chromeURL then UIApplication
sharedApplication openURL.
And otherwise, we will
default, or I guess fall back,
to the Safari URL.
So this time the application
does the right thing
on the simulator.
I click my fancy Open
a web page button
and it opens the google.com
Home page in Safari.
And when I go back
to my actual device,
and on my device, when I click
on this button, sure enough,
it now properly opens in Chrome.
So this is great.
But I'd like to explore
one other feature
that we haven't
really covered yet
and that's probably the
one most important to app
developers, which is the ability
to add that nice little back
button in Chrome that takes
users back to your application.
I know it seems
like a small thing
but being able to click
back with one press
as opposed to double
clicking the Home button
and then selecting your app
again from the multitasker
just feels like a much
smoother experience to me.
And we will show you how to do
that in the very next lesson.
So stick around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]